Muchas gracias por la invitación Bueno
podemos ver que en esta situación hay
una una crispación en la sociedad que
que no nació con este joven que que que
murió con exceso de la policía pero bien
antes cuando vemos la historia con 2005
conduvimos 2007 con
vemos que hay una crispación de la
sociedad alrededor de lo que es la
pregunta de la justicia hay mucho joven
que no se sienten a fuerzamente y
sienten como un sentimiento de
injusticia y hay una necesidad y lo
vemos por cada elección y las últimas
elecciones presidenciales de diálogo hoy
día en la sociedad en Francia lo vimos
con también la jubilación y todo esos
hechos esa acumulación digamos
hace que estamos en un país con
canciones y ese es una atención
que que que que pregunta sobre Cuál es
el diálogo mañana entre la póliza y la
juventud vemos Que hay muchos varios
populares vemos que hay muchas ciudades
donde hubo protestas hubo disturbios
no no declarado eso llama la atención de
Cuál es la política de la ciudad que hoy
día se está haciendo en Francia y se
hizo y y es una reflexión más amplia que
que que se está haciendo en la sociedad
actualmente en Francia claro y es que la
propia ONU a través de su oficina de
Derechos Humanos ha dicho que Francia
debía tratar el problema de racismo y
discriminación en su policía hay racismo
institucionalizado dentro de la policía
francesa
hay racismo institucional bueno Es según
los estudios según los desieres de de
algunos Sí hay hay un racismo como puede
haber racismo también en diferentes
también de de de de de la sociedad y
este racismo también participa también
este estas discriminación también de de
esos varios populares de estas de esos
distritos populares en Francia donde
siempre en la misma población participa
también a una necesidad también de de
justicia y ahora vemos perfiles de
juventud jóvenes de de Trece quince años
que salen en la calle por eso también el
presidente llamó a la responsabilidad de
de los padres que no se sienten
identificados en una política social
pese todos los ayuda los bonos que
también existen Francia todo también las
el sector asociativo que existe en
Francia Hay un problema a nivel social
que no se arregló en Francia y que sigue
siendo y sobre todo un racismo que
existe también en la sociedad claro
quería preguntarle En qué ha fallado el
estado para la integración de estos
jóvenes que en muchas ocasiones son
franceses hijos de migrantes y en la
atención a los suburbios de las ciudades
bueno que ha fallado yo creo que ese más
es una pregunta más amplia eh Como dijo
el presidente hay de un lado la
educación de los padres hay del otro
lado también muchos también niños
adolescentes que que ya no están también
en las escuelas que pasan dos tres
cuatro meses sin ir a la escuela
entonces Hay también una pregunta que de
social a una pregunta de la educación
como también a reformar también la
educación en Francia y tener una
igualdad también que sea por la las
personas que vienen que vienen de de
varios también populares como otros
también que tienen más allá más
facilidades también por el estatus
social ese Más bien es la pregunta no es
una falla solo solo del estado